مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابراز
العالم
يكشف رغبته بخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه في عام 2024 ويقول انه يجهز
لاعلان رسمي عن ذلك
البنتا يصف تسريب الوثائق الامريكيه
السريه بانه خرق امني خطير سيتسبب باضرار
جسيمه
روسيا يكشف عن مخاوفه ويطالب موسكو
بضمانات للدفاع عن بلاده اذا تعرضت لهجوم
الخارجيه التركيه تعلن انتقال انقره
والقاهره الى مرحله تبادل السفراء وتؤكد
موعد اللقاء الرباعي حول سوريا
[موسيقى]
دون تحديد الموعد كشف الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن عن خططه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
القادمه في عام 2024 مؤكدا انه جاري
التحضير للاعلان الرسمي وذلك اثناء سؤاله
من قبل مراسله قناه ام بي سي الامريكيه
وقالت وسائل الاعلام امريكيه تحدثت وقت
سابق عن غموض حول الوقت الذي سيعلن فيه
بايدن بدا حملته الانتخابيه بشكل رسمي في
وقت اظهرت استطلاعات راي امريكيه عدم رغبه
الديمقراطيين في ترشح بايدن لولايه ثانيه
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده على صفيح ساخن فبعد مثول
الرئيس السابق دانيل امام المحكمه في
الهاتف اصدرت لجنه الرقابه في مجلس النواب
الامريكيه مذكرات استدعاء رؤساء بنوك
وشركات لتحقيق بسجلات ماليه تخص عائله
الرئيس الامريكيه جو بايدن فلنتابع
حرب التحقيقات والتحقيقات المضاده بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين في الولايات
المتحده لا تكاد تضع اوزارها حتى تشتعل من
جديد على ايقاعات رئاسيه العام المقبل
لجنه الرقابه في مجلس وبالامريكي اصدرت
مذكرات استدعاء رؤساء بنوك وشركات للتحقيق
بسجلات ماليه تخص عائله الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن ونجله
استدعت بنك امريكا وكثي بانك وجيبي مورجان
الى
الشريك التجاري السابق لنجل ساكن البيت
الابيض هانتر بايدن لطلب السجلات الماليه
النائب جيميرا سكين وهو العضو الديمقراطي
الاعلى في لجنه الرقابه اشتكى من ان رئيس
اللجنه جيمس كومر الجمهوري من كنتاكي كان
يحاول اخفاء المعلومات المتعلقه بالتحقيق
من الديمقراطيين لجنه الرقابه في مجلس
النواب طلبت مساعده هانتر بايدن عبر
الادلاء بشهادته امامها مستشهده بالوثائق
الماليه التي تم الاستدعاء اليها وثائق
تظهر انه حول اكثر من مليون دولار الى
افراد عائله بايدن بعد تلقيه ثلاثه ملايين
دولار من شركه طاقه صينيه في عام 2017
فالى اين يصير قطار صراع التحقيقات بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين في الولايات
المتحده بلال البشتين العربيه
مزيد من التفاصيل المشاهدين ينضم الينا من
واشنطن حسين الطوب مراسل العربيه حسين
يعني ما هي اخر المعلومات التي ممكن ان
نزود فيها المشاهدين اليوم حول التحقيقات
التي فتحت بموضوع النرجل والتي هي ليست
بالجديد على كل حال هذا الملف ليس بالجديد
الكثيرون من الخبراء بان ما جرى قود
ثقه الامريكيين بالديمقرا بدمقراطيتهم
وايضا بالنظام القانوني لذلك نتوقع المزيد
من هذه التحقيقات ومن هذه الصدمات في
المستقبل القريب وحتى البعيد ليال يعني
بموازات حرب التحقيقات بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين والتي تصب يعني بصلب الحرب
السياسيه على ابواب الانتخابات الرئاسيه
نيه بايدن اليوم بهذا التوقيت اعلانه عن
نيته بالترشح الى الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله كيف تقراها الاوساط الامريكيه
وخصوصا الديمقراطيه منها
العيال هذه ليست اول مره يعلن الرئيس
بايدن عن نيته بالترشح لولايه ثانيه كان
من المتوقع ان يعلن عنها خلال خطاب حاله
الاتحاد في فبراير الماضي لكن ذلك لم يحدث
فتوقع البعض بان يعلن عن ترشحه في الربيع
وايضا هذا يحدث ويقول تقول اخر التقارير
واحدثها بانه قد يؤجل الموضوع حتى الصيف
الاعلان المتاخر بالنسبه للكثيرين هنا
يعطي الرئيس بايدن فرصه اكبر ليركز على
وظيفته كرئيس وايضا ليروج لاعماله للجمهور
كمان هناك عوامل عده
تساهم في هذا القرار منها ان لا يكون هناك
مرشح ديمقراطي في وجه الرئيس بايدن هذا
امر مستبعد جاره العاده لا يكون هناك مرشح
من الحزب نفسي اذا كان الرئيس يحق له
الترشح لولايه ثانيه هناك ايضا موضوع
التحضير من قبل الرئيس بايدن لمواجهه
قادمه مع الكونجرس الامريكي مع الجمهوريه
في الكونجر وخاصه في مجلس النواب بسبب
الانفاق الحكومي ورفع سقف الدين وهذا امر
مهم اضافه الى ان ايضا كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
توجيه التهم الى الرئيس السابق ضنال ترامب
جعلته يستهلك
الاعلام السياسي هنا الاضواء كلها الان
كانت متجهه نحوه الرئيس بايدن عندما يريد
ان يعلن عن ترشحه يجب ان يكون هو في صلب
هذا
الاعلام وهذه
بمعنى ان الاضواء يجب ان تكون مسلطه ويجب
ان يكون لديه انجازات ايضا يتحدث عنها
صحيح انه اقتصاديا هناك تقارير تتحدث عن
ان الوظائف تسير بشكل جيد في الولايات
المتحده ولكن يجب ان لا ننسى ايضا ان
التضخم ما زال مرتفعا رغما محاوله
هندسه كبح هذا التضخم لكن التضخم مازال
عاليا مازال هناك رفع لاسعار الفائده
وايضا هناك انتقادات كثيره من الجمهوريين
ان موضوع التضخم وهذه السنه الماليه ستكون
حاسمه يعني بالنسبه
وانعكاساتها على ملف ترشيحه وطبعا الجمهور
الديمقراطي شكرا لك حسين مراسل العربيه
حدثتنا من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان تسريب
الوثائق الاستخبارات يعتبر خرقا امنيا
سيتسبب باضرار جسيمه مضيفا بانها شبيهه
بتلك التي يتم تقديمها لكبار القاده وحذر
البنتاجون من ان التفاصيل في الوثائق
المسربه من الممكن ان تتسبب بخسائر في
الارواح وان بعض الصور في هذه الوثائق
يبدو انه تم تعديلها مشيره الى انه تم
اطلاع الوزير على تسريب يوم السادس من
ابريل وسيتم فتح تحقيق جنائي بهذا التسريب
الدفاع الامريكيه قالت كذلك انها اتخذت
اجراءات لمعرفه كيف تم توزيع هذه الوثائق
ومن الاشخاص الذين كانت لديهم القدره
للوصول اليها
الوثائق التي قد تهز ثقه الحلفاء
بالولايات المتحده وتعقد العلاقات
الخارجيه ظهرت للمره الاولى الى العلم على
قناه مراسله الصفحات العشر الاولى طبعت في
الثامن والعشرين من فبراير والثاني من
مارس على منصه باسم ديسكورد وهي منصه
دردشه يرتادها هواه الالعاب الالكترونيه
وفق صحيفه
وظلت المواد المصنفه سريه بين مجموعه
صغيره من مستخدمي المنصه حتى اوائل مارس
الماضي قبل ان يقوم مستخدم اخر باعاده
نشرها في مجموعه اخرى اكبر عددا طبعا غير
ان خروج هذه الوثائق للعلن على يد حساب
دعائي روسيه على منصه تيليجرام هذا
التسريب الاستخباراتي وانصفه بالاسوء
والاكثر ضررا منذ عقود يختلف عن سابقاته
اي ويكيليكس وادن بحداثه الوثائق فعمر بعض
المستندات لا يتجاوز الاربعين يوما
[موسيقى]
معلومات امريكيه مسربه حدث نادر لكنه في
كل مره يسبب الكثير من الاوجاع لاول مره
منذ سنه 2013
عشرات الوثائق بعضها يحمل واسما سريا
للغايه نشرت عبر الانترنت ورغم انها
مجهوله المصدر الا انها زرعت الشكوك بين
الحلفاء وغيرت خطه عسكريه كلفت الكثير
البدايه كانت في يناير الماضي وفي مكان
غير متوقع موقع ديسكورد للدردشه منصه
تستهوي هو العاب الفيديو دون غيرهم تنشر
وثائق جماعتها اعين امريكا التي لا تنام
المعلومات بقيت حبيسه غرفه دردشه واحده
قبل ان ينشرها الاسبوع الماضي احد الاعضاء
في مجموعه اخرى اكثر عددا وهنا تحولت
الوثائق الى فضيحه الصحف الامريكيه
استلهمت هذه المره كل مادتها الاعلاميه من
موقع الدردشه دون مصدر اخر
البنتاجون اكد صحه اذ لم ينفيها وهو الذي
سابق الزمن على جبهتين محاوله يئسه لحذف
الوثائق ومطارده الخونه في اروقه المكان
الاكثر سريه في العالم
وهنا فتح الباب امام الاحتمالات امريكا
تشارك معلوماتها الاستخباراتيه مع دول
محدوده منها كندا وبريطانيا وقد تكون هذه
الدول مصدر التسريب ولا مسؤوليه لواشنطن
في ذلك لكن الفرضيه لا تقدم اجابه بخصوص
وثائق لا يجب ان تغادر مبنى البينتاجون
احتمال ثاني عسكري رفيع يعمل لصالح موسكو
التي نشرت الوثائق بعد استغلالها والدليل
انها عادت لاستخدام طيرانها بكثافه تزامنا
مع انباء انهيار الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني
فرضيه اخرى طرحت نفسها بقوه الوثائق
ركزت على اوكرانيا واثبتت ما كان يعتبر
دعايه الكرملين امريكا تشارك وتخطط وتدعم
الحرب اركان حرب الوكاله لها من يرفضها
وفي اعلى المستويات لكن بعض الاصوات في
روسيا بدات تحذر من خدعه امريكيه تهدف
لمناوره استخباراتيه قد تكون الاكبر في
القرن الحالي
بلبله مستمره احدثتها وثائق البانتاجون
المسربه تفرعت عناوينها بين الاختراقات
والتجسس وخيانه الحلفاء لكن اضرارها لم
تتحدد بعد كما هويه المسرب الوثائق المئه
مشاهدينا اظهرت مدى عمق اختراق واشنطن
للاستخبارات الروسيه فقدمت تقييما لقوه
اله الحرب الروسيه والنتيجه جيش منهك
المواد المصنفه سريه للغايه اكد التقديم
موسكو مكافات ماليه لجنودها مقابل كل
دبابه غربيه يجري استهدافها او السيطره
عليها مع اقامه طبعا معسكرات تدريب للجنود
الروس حول نقاط ضعف دبابات النيتو الحاجه
للاسلحه على الجبهات وفق احدى الوثائق
دفعت مجموعه العسكريه للاتصال سرا بجهات
تركيا في فبراير الماضي بمحاوله للحصول
على اسلحه ومعدات الجانب التركي الجيش
الاوكراني هو الاخر في حاله يرسلها دفاعات
جويه لن تصمد اكثر ومخزونات ذخيره فارغه
بحسب الوثائق وثائق البنتاجون افادت كذلك
بوجود قوات من حلف الناتو في اوكرانيا
بينهم فرنسيون وامريكيون وبريطانيون تجسس
واشنطن على الاعداء قابله ادله بالوثائق
على تجسسها على اقرب الحلفاء مثل اسرائيل
وكوريا الجنوبيه ما ينذر بتعقيد العلاقات
مع واشنطن فالحليل في الاسيوي اي كوريا
الجنوبيه نالت حصتها من هذه الوثائق فكشفت
هنا مشاهدينا مناقشات خاصه بين كبار
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين الجنوبيين حول
الضغط الامريكي عليها للمساعده بامداد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه رغم ان سياسه سول
تتعارض مع ذلك
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا مشاهدينا من باريس مايا خضراء
الكاتبه السياسيه للحديث عن ملف دخول
القوات القوات النيتو في هذه الحرب بعد
تسريبات وثائق البانداغون مساء الخير
استاذه مايا يعني اليوم هذه التسريبات بين
الانقسام حول من حرب التضليل الى مدى صحه
هذه الوثائق طبعا فرنسا محرجه وهي بالنصف
خصوصا انها تاتي وتعارض النهج الحذر
لماكرون منذ بدايه هذه الحرب وحتى هذه
الساعه ماذا يعني ذلك
كل ذلك يدخل في حرب المعلومات التي نشهدها
منذ بدا الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه او
الغزو الروسي على اوكرانيا وهذا التسريب
خطير جدا لانه تسريب مضلل لا نعرف ما
مصدره نعلم ان هذه الوثائق هي وثائق
امريكيه لا يمكن الوصول اليها الا من
الجانب الامريكي او من العناصر الامريكيه
ولكن هناك سيناريوهات كثيره تم التباحث
فيها اي التسريب اتى عبر الامريكيين كما
كما قلت لكم او عبر الروس او عملاء روس في
الولايات المتحده او ثالثا كان هناك
تسريبا امريكيا استفادت منه روسيا لتغيير
بعض من المعلومات وهذا ما رايناه اول ما
تم نشر او تسريب هذه على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تيليجرام وتويتر كان هناك وثائق
اوليه وكان هناك نسخ جديده عن هذه الوثائق
تم تعديلها من ناحيه ارقام الخسائر في
الصفوف الاوكرانيه والروسيه وتم التداول
بها في كافه وسائل الاعلام الروسيه لذلك
اليوم يوجد ضبابيه كبيره حول هذه
التسريبات ولكن من المؤكد ان هذه
التسريبات بالرغم من خطورتها هي تتركز على
الاشهر المنصرمه في الحرب
في اوكرانيا ولا تبين او لا تنشر الكثير
من المعلومات او القليل من المعلومات عن
الاشهر التي
نشرها او تسريبها ولكن بملف يعني خصوصا
العلاقه مع الحلفاء هي محرجه نوعا ما لبعض
الدول ومنها باريس باريس منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب ساعه لان تاخذ وهي تاريخيا ايضا
لديها موقف مغاير عن موقف واشنطن ولكنها
كانت محدوده يعني هذا السعي كان محدود
بسبب حساسيه الحرب على الارض الاوروبيه
هذا السعي للانفصال على الموقف الامريكي
يتجلى اكثر بالعلاقات مع الصين الى اي مدى
التصريح الذي سمعناه مؤخرا لرئيس الفرنسي
ممكن ان يؤثر على التعاون الامريكي
الفرنسي بملف اوكرانيا وبالملفات الاخرى
هو هذا التصريح تصريح خطير يعني بعد هذه
الزياره
ذات الرمزيه الكبيره على الصعيد
الدبلوماسي التي رافقها او رافقته اليها
ارسل ليا رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه لقد
قام الرئيس ماكرون بالتصريح عن الكثير من
الامور خاصه هذا الموقف الذي يتعارض مع
الموقف الامريكي من الصين وهو يقول ان كل
ما يحدث ما بين الصين وتايوان هو
استفزازات امريكيه ويتم الرد عليها بشكل
مبالغ من قبل الصين ولكنه بشكل واضح جدا
حمل المسؤوليه الى الجانب الامريكي هذا
ياتي ليعكر
الاجواء التي لم تكن على ما يرام ما بين
الولايات المتحده والجانب الفرنسي وتسريب
وثائق بانتاجون كلها تزاملت يبين ان
مناحيه كلها تزامنت وكانه يوجد نوع من
الابتزاز
ممكن بشكل غير مباشر ان تمارسه الولايات
المتحده على الطرف الفرنسي لتسليط الضوء
نعم تسليط الضوء على الدور الفرنسي
والبريطاني ايضا
موضوع فتح الساعه الاوروبي اليوم لفتح
جسور مع يعني تكتل العالم الجديد خصوصا ان
الجانب الفرنسي تحديدا يواجه ضغوطات
اقتصاديه كبيره في الداخل وهو لن يعيد
الغلط الذي نوعا ما حدث بحارب اوكرانيا
هذا الضغوط الداخليه اليوم الى اي مدى
ممكن ان تؤثر وتدفع نحو التباعد الفرنسي
الامريكي بالمواقف بالسياسه الخارجيه
يعني هناك بالفعل الكثير من الضغوط
الداخليه وهناك ايضا سياسه اوروبيه لقد
بدات
بالاختلاف عن السياسه الامريكيه بعدما كان
هناك اقرار لخطه مكافحه الازمه الماليه في
الولايات المتحده او التضخم كان هناك خطه
اوروبيه موازيه وهذه الخطه جعلت الطلب
الطرف الامريكي يمتعد نوعا ما لذلك منذ
بدا الحرب الاوكرانيه كان هناك تفاوت
بوجوهات النظر على الصعيد الاقتصادي على
صعيد امداد الاسلحه امداد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه واليوم نرى ان هذا التفاوت ايضا
يطال الجانب الدبلوماسي فرنسا تريد ان
تسرع المفاوضات ما بين الجانب الروسي
واوكرانيا تريد التقرب من الصين
لاعاده انعاش المصالح الاقتصاديه لذلك
كانت هذه الزياره الرمزيه خصوصا ان الشريك
الاول اق
بالفعل على صعيد الصادرات والواردات فرنسا
والصين لديهما علاقه وطيده تضررت بعد ازمه
الكوفيد 19 وهي تريد احياء هذه العلاقه
وهذا ما يجعلها تبتعد عن الولايات المتحده
شكرا لكن ارى ان الابتعاد التام طبعا ليس
ابتعاد تام ولكن
شكرا لك استاذه مايا خضراء الكاتبه
السياسيه حدثنا من باريس عذرا على الضيق
الوقت
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
القوات الامريكيه في سوريا تسقط صواريخ
اطلقت على قاعده لها شرق دير الزور
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد شارك عدد من وزراء
الحكومه الاسرائيليه واعضاء في الكنيسه
المسيره بالضفه الغربيه لدعم الاستيطان
توجه المشاركين بالمسيره التي شارك بها
سبعه وزراء على راسهم وزير الامن القومي
اتمار بن قفير ووزير الماليه بصحبه نحو 20
عضوا بالكنيسه الى بؤره استيطانيه تم
اخلائها قبل عامين على قمه جبل صبيح جنوبي
مدينه نابلس حيث انضموا الى مئات
المستوطنين في مسيره امتدت لساعات
هذا واطلقت القوات الاسرائيليه وابلا من
الغاز تجاه شبان فلسطينيين وذلك خلال
مواجهات اندلعت على جبل صبيح حيث نظم
المستوطنون مسيره للضغط من اجل شرعنه
الاستيطان
[موسيقى]
حمل رئيس الوزراء الفلسطينيه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كامل المسؤوليه عن كل ما يجري
بالمنطقه مطالبا العالم بمحاسبه اسرائيل
على جرائمها اليوميه واخرها العدوان على
المسجد الاقصى
ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه تتحمل كامل
المسؤوليه عن كل ما يجري هنا وفي المنطقه
اجمع وان لغه العدوان والتطرف التي يدينها
العالم مطلوب من هذا العالم محاسبه هذه
الحكومه على جرائمها المتكرره يوميا والتي
كان اخرها العدوان على الاقصى ومسيره
الوزراء واعضاء الكنيست المؤيده والداعمه
للاستيطان والاجتياحات والقتل المبرمج
قال الرئيس البلاروسي الكسندر لوكاشينكو
خلال اجتماع مع وزير الدفاع الروسيه انه
يريد ضمانات بان موسكو ستدافع عن بلاده
اذا تعرضت للهجوم مؤكدا ان هناك ناقش
الامر سابقا مع الرئيس الروسي الذي اتفق
معه على ضروره هذه الضمانات الامنيه
فلنتابع
في حاله وقوع هجوم على بيلاروسيا فان
الاتحاد الروسي سيدافعا بيلاروسيا مثل
الدفاع عن اقليمه هذا هو نوع الضمان الذي
نحتاجه في التسعينات تمت المناقشه على هذا
بشكل او باخر هذا هو نوع الضمان الذي
نحتاج اليه في التسعينات تمت المناقشه على
هذا بشكل او باخر والان وبسبب ما يفعله
الغرب لقد تم نسيانه ما هي ضمانات السلامه
التي يمكن ان توفرها لنا الولايات المتحده
لا شيء ولذلك نحتاج الى ضمانات امنيه
كامله من اخواننا في روسيا
الى التطورات على الارض وتحديدا في
اوكرانيا حيث قال رئيس دونياسك الموالي
لروسيا
دينيس بوشيلين قال ان حوالي
75% من مدينه بخموت اصبحت تحت تحت سيطره
القوات الروسيه هنا نتحدث عن داخل المدينه
وتحديدا عن سيطره قوات فاجنر على المباني
الاداريه لهذه المدينه وهنا بوسط المدينه
طبعا التصريحات الروسيه والاوكرانيه هنا
متناقضه حول موضوع السيطره الكامله على
هذه المدينه والتي تخوض طبعا القوات
الاوكرانيه فيها والروسيه معارك شرسه في
منطقه تجمع السكك الحديديه داخل المدينه
وتحديدا بوسط مركز بخموت معارك ايضا شرسه
تدور في المنطقه الشماليه وتحديدا على
اطراف مدينه اريخ في غربي هذه
المنطقه اذا هذه المعارك تدور هنا في هذه
المنطقه على اطراف مدينه بخموت وايضا
ببلده
تحاول القوات الروسيه هنا اقتحام المنطقه
باعداد كبيره من المقاتلين طبعا لقوات
فاجنر دور اساسي بهذه المناطق وبهذه
العمليه لقطع الطريق من مدينه تشاسوفير
غرب المدينه وتحاول هنا ايضا اكمال
السيطره على هذه المنطقه وقطع الطريق هنا
بهذه النقطه تحديدا لاكمال السيطره على كل
مخمود التي تعتبر تعتبر منطقه استراتيجيه
والحرب دائره فيها منذ اكثر من شهر وطبعا
حرب التصريحات بين كل من الجانب الروسي
والاوكراني موجوده منذ اكثر من شهر
وتحديدا فاقنر بال
ومع اقتراب هجوم الربيع الموعود
روح حاول اتخاذ وضعيه الاستعداد وجمع ما
تيسر من اسلحه غربيه لكن نفاذ الذخيره
يرافقه قصور بصفوف القوات الاوكرانيه ما
اوجد ضروره للتعبئه في وقت سابق يستجيب
بعض الاوكرانيين للملصقات على طرق السريعه
والتي تدعو المدنيين للانضمام
للقتال وتحويل الغضب مشاهدينا سانتقل الى
مؤتمر صحفي في البيت الابيض واعود من
بعدها لمتابعه الملف الاوكراني
التي لا يتم منح تصريح امني بموجبها
وهناك جهود حثاثه تتعلق بمعالجه تلك
المعلومات السريه واعطائي التصاريح
الامنيه المطلوبه للموظفين تتمه بطريقه
مدروسه بالعوده لسؤالك يجب علينا ان نتوخل
الحذر الان
التكهن او التخمين حول ما قد يكونوا خلف
ما يبدو بانه تسريب محتمل لمعلومات سريه
لا بد من اجراء عمليه
حسب الاصول هل تتحدثون عن ان هناك
تمت تسريبًا قد حدث من قبل لشخص ما
انتم
سمعتم عن هذا الامر قبل يومين
وسوف تتولى وزاره العدل العامه للاهاب
والتحقيق بالامر مره اخرى
رغم ما قيل فان وزاره الدفاع قد ذكرت
بانها تنظر الى مساله توزيع قدره الوصول
لهذه المعلومات واجراء تغييرات اداريه
لديهم
الكم الاكبر من هذه المستندات لكن لابد
لنا ان نعلم ما الذي حدث وهذا الامر قد
تتولى وزاره العدل النظر فيه هل لديكم اي
فكره عن عدد الاشخاص الذين كان لهم قدره
الوصول لهذه المعلومات
هل هناك المئات نظرا لهذا التسريب تسريب
المستندات فان
الولايات المتحده قد تخسروا معركتها سواء
مع القراصنه او مع اي شخص يرغبه بمعرفه اي
معلومات حولنا الرئيس قد تمت احاطته هذا
حول هذا الامر
ويتم النظر فيه بصوره جاده من خلال الجهود
التي يتم بحثها والنظر في التداعيات
الامنيه التي قد تنبع عن هذا الامر ووزاره
العدل تتولى اداره تحقيق جنائي ناخذ هذا
الامر على محمل الجد
هو ما من اعذار مقبوله لمثل هذه المسندات
التي يتم تسريبها فهي لا يجب ان تكون في
متاحه للعامه
اذا ما كان هناك ثمه اجراء يجب اتخاذه
فكلما نعلم عن النطاق ما حدث من هذا من
تسريب المستندات فسوف نتخذ الخطه بناء على
ذلك
هل تحدث الرئيس بايدن مع نظيره الرئيس
زيلينسكي حول تسريب تلك المستندات وحول
سلامه المعلومات المسؤولون الامريكيون
كانوا على اتصالا مع نظرائهم وحلفائهم
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
هل نتحدث عن
مساله التسريب المستندات ام ام فقط
معلومات اخرى قد تم
تسريبها لاشخاص وقام هؤلاء بالتلاعب بها
وتغيير طبيعتها لا اعلم اذا ما كنا قد
وصلنا الى هذا الامر لكن في بعض الحالات
على الاقل فان المعلومات التي تم نشرها
عبر الشبكه قد تم تغييرها مما هي عليه في
مصدرها الاصلي هذا ما استطيع ان اخبركم به
وكيف
ولا نعلم كيف حدث هذا الامر لكننا نسعى
لفهم ما حدث بصوره دقيقه
وبالعوده لنقطتك فاننا نهيب بكم جميعا ان
تتوخوا الحذر حول كيفيه سرد القصص الصحفيه
بشان هذه المعلومات المسربه سؤالان
السؤال الاول حول الصين ذكرتم ان ذلك كان
رد فعل قد يكون اورده فعلا مبالغا فيه من
قبل الصين الى اي حد انتم واثقون بانهم ما
من ردود افعال اخرى قد تنبع من طرف الصين
وقد تدفعه للصراع
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا ثانيا اولئك الذين
القائمون على
سريه ومسؤوليتي تلك المستندات كانوا قد
قدموا ضمانات بان لن تتم قرصه قرص قرصنتنا
او اجراء قصتنا هل يمكن الحكومه ان تقوم
بعرقله اي محاوله من هذا النوع في
المستقبل فيما يخص علاقتنا مع اوكرانيا
فلن تتغير وانا لن اتحدث عن اي مستند
بعينه سوف اتحدث عن المعلومات الاستخباره
سؤالك كان حول اذا ما كان هناك اي اثر على
دعم اوكرانيا فسوف نستمر في دعم اوكرانيا
كما قال الرئيس مهما استغرق الامر من زمن
هو بالنسبه لموضوع
التقنيه التصدي الى القرصنه لا اعلم لا
يمكنه الحديث عن هذا
البيت الابيض والذي تركز طبعا على موضوع
تسريب الوثائق الوثائق البانتاجون بالعوده
الى الملف الاوكرانيه وتحديدا مع اقتراب
هجوم الربيع الموعود روسيا تتحضر والدفاع
الاوكرانيه يحاول اتخاذ وضعيه الاستعداد
وجمع ما تيسر من اسلحه غربيه لكن نفاذ
الزخير يرافقه قصور بصفوف القوات
الاوكرانيه ما اوجد ضروره للتعبئه
العسكريه وفي وقت يستجيب بعض الاوكرانيين
للملصقات على الطريق السريعه والتي تدعو
المدنيين للانضمام للقتال تحويل الغضب الى
سلاح تتسبب هذه المنشورات بتخويف اخرين
غير راغبين بالخدمه العسكريه وهنا تبدا
عمليات التجنيد رجال يرتدون الزي العسكري
يظهرون بكل مكان وفي اي وقت بحسب واشنطن
يطرقون الابواب او يقفون ويوقفون المدنيين
بشكل عشوائي في زوايا الشوارع ويوزعون
اوراقا قد تقلب حيات هؤلاء راسا على عقب
علما بانه في السابق كان بامكان المسؤولين
تسليم مسودات الاوراق فقط الى منازل
الاشخاص حينها كان يمكن تجنب الاخطارات
بتغيير عناوين السكن الرسميه في المناطق
الاوكرانيه هذا وتمنع مشاهدينا الاحكام
العرفيه المعمول بها في اوكرانيا منذ
فبراير من عام 2022 الرجال الذين تتراوح
اعمارهم بين 18 عاما و60 عاما من مغادره
البلاد كلها
[موسيقى]
فيما مخزونات القوات الاوكرانيه تجف شيئا
فشيء تشتكي كيف من قنابل جويه روسيه معدله
جديده من طراز اف اي بي فايف حيث حذرت
اوكرانيا من استخدام روسيا لقنابل ذكيه
موجهه مثل فاب 5 في الاشهر الاخيره هذه
القنابل وزنها 500 كيلو جرام تسقط في الجو
براس حربي شديد الانفجار القنبله غير
موجهه وهي متوافقه مع معظم الطائرات
السوفيتيه تم تجهيزها بوحده تخطيط وتصحيح
تحول القنابل العاديه تحول القنابل
العاديه الى قنبله عاليه الدقه ما اعطى
الطائرات الروسيه من طراز سوق 34 35
القدره على تحديد انظمه الدفاع الجويه
الاوكرانيه من خلال اطلاق 20 قنبله موجهه
يوميا
للحديث اكثر عن سير المعارك ينضم الينا من
العاصمه الاوكرانيه حذيفه عادل مراسل
العربيه من كييف حذيفه
المعارك في بخموت اليوم هناك تصريحات
متضاربه اخر يعني التحديثات حول سير هذه
المعارك معك لو سمحت
مساء الخير دعيه ابدا بما ذكره الصحفي
الاوكراني اندريه
الذي قدم تقريرا من هناك وقال ان القوات
الروسيه تسيطر على ثلثي مدينه هذا الحديث
يدور عن المدينه نفسها ولكن جبهه باخ مت
ليالي هي جبهه عريضه يعني تقتصر فقط على
مدينه باقود نفسها وانما تمتد في اتجاه
افديفكا ومارينكا وحتى الطريقه المؤدي الى
اتجاه ماريوبل والتي تسمى تافرسكي
كما يسميها الاوكران ولديها قياده حتى
منفصله كل هذه المنطقه تسمى جبهه بخموت
لان القوات الروسيه تحاول التقدم خلاف
حصار مدينه مخبوط نفسها اكمال السيطره على
ما تبقى من اراضي جونس ثم التقدم في اتجاه
كروماتورسكو واتجاه ماسك لاكمال السيطره
على الحدود الاداريه
الكسندر ستيرسكي قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه كانت في زياره اليوم الى مخموت
يعني قدم رساله من هناك اولا تحدث عن ان
القوات الاوكرانيه ارهقت قوات فاجنر في
ضخموت واصبحت القوات الروسيه تدفع بقوات
خاصه
وبعض القوات من
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني وايضا تدعم
بالسلاح الطيران
الروسي في العمليات في مخبوط الامر الذي
غاب في السابق ذلك نسبه لما قال ان فشل
قوات فاجنر في اكمال السيطره وفي اكمال
مهمتها لذلك الان يتم الاستعانه بقوات
خاصه بالقوات الاتحاد الروسي كان هنالك
عمليه قص طبعا استطاعت القوات الاوكرانيه
ان تصب 20 هجمه اليوم فقط في ضخموت وايضا
نفذت القوات الروسيه اكثر من 36 ضربه
بالرجمات الصواريخ كذلك قامت بقصف بخمسه
صواريخ اربعه منها استهدفت التي طبعا
العين عليها بعد اباق متولاتنا القوات
الاوكرانيه تؤكد وزاره الدفاع خطابها
المسائي تؤكد انها ما زالت تسيطر على
الوضع في مخبوط وتدافع عن المدينه شكرا لك
يا حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه حدثنا
[موسيقى]
الى سوريا حيث قال المرصات السوريه ان
قوات التحالف الدوليه المتمركزه في قاعده
حقل كونيكو للغاز اسقط طائره مسيره حيث
سقطت في قريه الطابيه بريف دير الزور
الشرقي كما تحدثت وسائل اعلام كرديه عن
اسقاط صواريخ كانت تستهدف حقل كونيكو في
دير الزور
[موسيقى]
سيناريوهات متعدده حاكت غزوه صينيا
للجزيره التايوانيه خسائرها فادحه ومحتمه
طبعا على الطرفين طرفي الصراع غير ان
التدريبات الصينيه الاخيره
واستفزازاتها المتكرره لتايوان ضاعفت من
مخاوف التصعيد ووقوع حرب بالفعل بين
الطرفين ففي ثالث ايام ما سمتها تدريبات
السيف المشترك نشرت القوات الجويه الصينيه
عشرات الطائرات لفرض حصار جوي على الجزيره
بمشاركه طبعا حامله الطائرات شاندونغ
بينما تنفذت قواتها البريه تدريبات على
ضربات دقيقه متعدده الاهداف بكين التي
وصفت المناورات بالتحذير الجديد والحازم
نشرت مدمرات وقاذفات صواريخ وطوارق سريعه
قاذفه للصواريخ ومقاتلات واجهزه تشويش
بهذه المناورات علما بان مناورات اليوم
تجرى بالذخيره الحيه في م تايوان قرب
الساحل ساحل مقاضعه فوديان الواقعه مقابل
الجزيره طبعا جزيره تايوان اما المسافه
بين الساحل الصيني والجزيره فتبلغ عند
اقرب نقطه من المضيق نحو 130 كيلومترا هنا
الولايات المتحده مشاهدينا لم تكتفي
بمراقبه الوضع بل ارسلت المدمره الامريكيه
ميليوس لتبحر في منطقه بحر الصين الجنوبي
وهو الامر الذي اعتبرته طبعا بكين
استفزازا
[موسيقى]
المدمرات تشق طريقها في مياه بحر الصين
الجنوبي
اصطحاله ترقب صينيه بسبب توغل السفينه
الامريكيه في مياه الصين الاقليميه فما هي
قدرات هذه السفينه الحربيه
المدمره قادره على القيام بمهام متعدده
لاداء حرب مضاده للطائرات والسفن
والغواصات كل ذلك في وقت واحد كما انها
قادره على اكتشاف الصواريخ الباليستيه
وتتبعها والاشتباك معها
وذلك عن طريق رادار الصفيف المرحلي متعدد
الوظائف
تحمل هذه السفن صواريخ مسيره وصواريخ
هاربون المضاده للسفن
هذا وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
خصوصين وحدها وان تهديد السلام يتمثل
باستقلال تايوان فلنستمع لما قاله
هذا ان مساله تايوان شان داخلي يخص الصين
وحدها وذلك وفق مبدا الصين الواحده هناك
اجماع واسع النطاق في المجتمع الدولي
ومعيار اساسي للعلاقه الدوليه اما في
الوقت الحالي يتمثل التهديد الاكبر للسلام
في المضيق تايوان في النزعه الانفصاليه
لاستقلال تايوان والتواطؤ على ذلك والدعم
من القوات الاجنبيه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولود شاوجلو
ان نظيره المصري سامح شكري سيزور انقره
قريبا هذا الاسبوع واضاف وزير الخارجيه
التركيه في تصريحات نقلتها وكاله الاناضول
ان انقره والقاهره تقتربان من مرحله تعيين
السفراء بين البلدين
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
هذا كاران
[موسيقى]
الجبل الاحمر دراما تونسيه تثير الجدل
على
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نستكمل التاسعه هذا
المساء من الحرمين واخبار المعتمرين خلال
شهر رمضان الكريم
[موسيقى]
خصصت الجهات المعنيه في السعوديه المئات
من الكوادر البشريه من مهندسين وفنيين
ومراقبين وعماله يعملون على مدار الساعه
من اجل راحه وسلامه قاصديه المسجد الحرام
في التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه التي تم
فتحها امام المعتمرين والمصلين خلال شهر
رمضان واكدت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين ممثله في
وكاله التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه جاهزيه
التوسعه الثالثه بالمسجد الحرام لاستقبال
المصلين خلال الشهر خلال العشر الاواخر من
رمضان من خلال منظومه الخدمات الميدانيه
والهندسيه والفنيه وتنفيذ الاعمال وفق خطط
تشغيليه تم الاعداد لها في وقت سابق
لنقل الصوره من هناك مشاهدينا ينضم الينا
من الحرم المكي المراسل العربيه اسامه
القاسم اسامه كيف هي الصوره لديك لو سمحت
اهلا وسهلا تحيه طيبه لكم ولجميع مشاهدين
العربيه نعمل
توسعه التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه اليوم في
الحرم المكي الشريف طبعا رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين اعلنت عن استكمال الاعمال لتهيئه
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه لاستقبال الزوار
والمصلين التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه تتسع
لحوالي مليون و200 الف مصلي ننقل لكم
الصوره الان هنا في التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه وبالحديث عن الخدمات اليوم التي
تقدم في التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه بجاره
تنفيذ الخطط الخدميه في ادوار مبنى
التوسعه كافه نتحدث عن خمسه ادوار وايضا
الاسطح التي تفتح لاول مره في شهر رمضان
المبارك ايضا تكثيف عمليات النظافه
والتعطير هناك اكثر من 4000 عامل على مدار
الساعه يعملون للتاكد من تشغيل ايضا
مشربيات ماء زمزم وتامين الحافظات وتجهيز
الابواب وتامين السجاد ايضا تحدث الان
وبامامنا بالضبط باب مئه واكبر ابواب
الحرمين الشريفين وايضا هو يعتبر اكبر باب
بالعالم ايضا تشغيل المصاعد والسلالم
الكهربائيه ايضا ليال وتشغيل نظام التكييف
وفق معايير تراعي درجه حراره الجو ونقاء
الهواء نتحدث ايضا اليوم عن الكثير من
الخدمات التي تقدم هناك اكثر من الف عامل
يعملون في سقيا زمزم واربعه الاف عامل
يعملون لتنظيف وفرش سجاديد المسجد الحرام
نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن تعطير المسجد الحرام
على مدار اربعه وعشرين ساعه هذه الخدمات
التي تقدم من اجل ان يعيش هذا الزائر
والمعتمر تجربه استثنائيه اثناء وصوله الى
الحرم المكي نشاهد الان ايضا هذه الزحام
امام بوابه رقم مئه ونشاهد ايضا المصلين
نحن نتحدث الان ايضا اثناء اداء صلاه
التراويح في الحرم المكي ونشاهد هذه
الاعداد الغفيره من الزوار والمعتمرين كل
هذه الخدمات بالتاكيد اتت ضمنا لاستكمال
الخطه التشغيليه الاولى والثانيه التي
اعلنوا نجاحها هذا اليوم ثم بدا الخطه
التشغيليه الثالثه هي الخاصه ايضا بالعشر
الاواخر وهي الخطه التشغيليه الاكبر التي
ستبدا غدا من اجل رعايه هؤلاء الزوار
والمعتمرين ضمن العشر الاواخر الرئاسه
ايضا اعلنت اصدار تصاريح للاعتكاف هناك
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف معتكف ومعتكفه في
الحرم المكي يقعون في بساحه المسجد الحرام
وتوسعه الملك فهد والتوسعه الشماليه
والتوسعه السعوديه الثالثه كل هذه الخدمات
بالتاكيد سيتزيد الجهات تكثيفها خلال ايام
القادمه لان العشر الاواخر تشهد توافد
الكثير من الزوار والمعتمرين نتحدث اليوم
ايضا عن الحركه التنقليه من والى الحرم
المكي الحركه تشهد تيسيرا كبيرا جدا هناك
حافلات النقل العام تنقل الزوار
والمعتمرين من مناطق سكنهم وايضا من مناطق
وقوف مركباتهم وتوصلهم الى المسجد الحرام
كل هذه الخدمات سنشهدها ايضا في النشرات
القادمه وفي الايام القادمه من هنا من
الحرم المكي ليالي شكرا لك اسامه القاسم
مراسل العربيه حدثتنا من الحرم شكرا على
هذه الرساله
[موسيقى]
في دراما رمضان جدل كبير على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بعدما طال مقص الرقيب
مسلسل الجبل الاحمر التونسي وحذف بعض
المشاهد بحجه انها لا تتماشى مع طبيعه شهر
رمضان المزيد مشاهدينا في تقرير كواليس مع
سهى الوعل وايهم القاسم
[موسيقى]
اما مازلنا في الطرح العالم اللي تظلم
مخبل في الكبه وكل شيء مكسور
[موسيقى]
مرحبا ضجه كبيره ويثيرها حاليا مسلسل
التونسي الجبل الاحمر اللي يحكي قصص
واقعيه التقى فيها مخرج العمل باصحابها او
اقاربهم او اصدقائهم حيث امضت ورشه كتابه
المسلسل اربعه اشهر شارك فيها كتاب
معروفين ومؤرخين ايضا هو مسلسل عشرين حلقه
من 45 دقيقه
فيه عدد كبير من نجوم تقريبا 70 من سبعين
الى 80% من الكاستينغو نجوم صف اول
التوانسه مسلسل بالاسيس اجتماعي
تشويق واثاره لما هي الشخصيه فيها تلوينات
فيها تضاريس فيها اشياء منتظره كما انه
فيها اشياء غير منتظره تماما هي مثل
الشخصيات
تراجيديه والشخصيات الملحميه اللي تعيش
تجربه
بدايه ووسط ونهايه
وفي الواقع هي ككل الشخصيات
الموجوده بيناتنا كذلك انما تميزها
تجربتها الخاصه المسلسل الاجتماعي
وحكاياته على مستوى المضمون جبال الاحمر
يقوم على اهم عناصر الدراما اللي هم مثلث
السلطه والحب والموت وهو يحاكي ويقع
الاحياء الشعبيه
وتناول موضوع من اهم المواضيع الشركه في
وقتنا هذا اللي هو ظاهره الفساد الفساد
اللي عنده اوجه متعدده فساد قيامه فساد
معنوي فساد سياسي وانعكاسات على حياه
الاحياء الشعبيه كتابه الشخصيات في هذا
المجال كتبت بشكل واقعي تجد عن نفس
الشخصيه جانب جيد وجانب قد يكون سيء او
جانب متسامح وقد يوجد في لحظه من اللحظات
جانب عنيف وهو واقعي جدا
فساعدنا سيناريو في بناء الشخصيات متاعنا
المخرج ربي يقول انه فكره المسلسل انطلقت
لحظه امراه مامو موقف غريب كان ضحيه هذا
موقف شاب تمت معاملته بشكل سيء فقط لانه
ينتمي للحياه الشعبي اللي تدور فيه احداث
العمل رجاء مسلسل الجبل الاحمر ليسال
لماذا
مبروك انظروا
[موسيقى]
مراسم التتويج المنتظره للملك تشارلز
الثالث فخامه وبهرجه ليست بزائفه بل احياء
تقاليد تعود الى الفعل قصر كشف عن بعض
التفاصيل المتعلقه بمراسم التتويج المقرره
في السادس من شهر مايو المقبل في
كاتدرائيه
مع زوجته كاملا الى الكاتدرائيه في احدث
عربه ملكيه وهي عربه اليوبيل التي صممت
للاحتفال بمرور 60 عاما على اعتلاء الملكه
اليزابيث عرش بريطانيا مده المراسم اقصر
من تلك التي استغرقتها مراسم تنصيب والده
تشارلز الراحله قبل 70 عاما الاختلاف
بينهما يشمل ايضا حجم الحدث ليتماشى جزئيا
مع العصر الحديث ويعكس ازمه تكاليف
المعيشه الحاليه وبعد الانتهاء من
سيعود تشارلز وكاميلا الى قصر باكينغهام
في اقدم عربه ملكيه وهي العربه الملكيه
المذهبه التي تعود الى 260 عاما
[موسيقى]
تعرضت طائره تابعه لشركه
الى حادث اثناء هبوطها في المطار حيث
انكسرت عجله الهبوط الاماميه مدفع الطائره
الى الانزلاق على المدرج وتكوين مسار من
الشرر ولكن انتهى الحادث دون تسجيل اصابات
فلنتابع ماذا حصل
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
يكشف رغبته بخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه في عام 2024 اقول انه يجهز
للاعلان رسميا عن ذلك
[موسيقى]
يصف تسريب الوثائق الامريكيه السريه بانه
خرق امني خطير سيتسبب باضرار جسيمه
بيلا يكشف عن مخاوفه ويطالب موسكو بضمانات
الدفاع عن بلاده اذا تعرضت
لهجوم
الخارجيه التركيه تعلن انتقال انقره
والقاهره الى مرحله تبادل السفراء وتؤكد
موعد اللقاء الرباعي حول سوريا
الى هنا اتي مشاهدينا الى ختام التاسعه
ولكن اخبار العربيه مستمره كما كل ليله
والان الى 360 مع زملاء راويه وطاهر راويه
وطاهر مساء الخير وماذا لديكم مساء الخير
الحمد لله على السلامه
نحن سنتحدث لنعرف المزيد من التفاصيل بشان
سبل الحوار القائمه حاليا بين الوفد
السعودي العماني من جهه الحوثي في صنعاء
والى اين وصلت قضيه التسريبات للوثائق
الامريكيه وايضا استراتيجيه بايدن
الانتخابات عام 2024 تابعي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات